[Music]
movie reviews
i'm sorry okay i'm not planning i wasn't
planning to make more
but have you watched the new star wars
oh my god
i'm the biggest star wars fan ever
i'm not really that big of a star wars
fan uh
seeing all the following and excitement
for
this latest film i was actually pretty
excited about seeing it as well
but while watching the film i find
myself just
not enjoying it i thought it was really
bad
but then i go
felix this is star wars
everyone loves star wars stop
being such a cynic and enjoy the film so
i keep watching but then i don't know
where
comes a joke so bad that it makes your
whole
face just turn inside out
no felix this is star wars it's got 94
percent
on rotten tomatoes if you don't like
this movie then you
there is something wrong with you okay
there is clearly something wrong
you don't know how to criticize a movie
felix that's why
you don't stick to your meme reviews
felix you don't like star wars
so i keep watching okay maybe i was one
back joking
it doesn't matter i love star wars
then another joke hits you god oh god
what was that was that even a joke
what the hell i love the joke oh my god
damn it
[Music]
you know you know a movie has bad humor
if i'm the one criticizing it
for bad humor movie review it felt like
the lily pawns of comedy
just uh people getting hurt and you're
expected to go and that's funny
he got hurt he fell
that's hilarious i see so many people
defending this movie online this
despite the 94
critic review how how how does this
movie have 94
how don't get me wrong
it wasn't bad but 94
jesus christ so many people want to like
this film so badly and seeing people's
reaction to
uh to it and and defending it is is
hilarious to me
i found this tweet uh and i've seen a
lot of people say the same thing
man a second viewing of the last jedi
really did the trick turned me from a
like to a lover i love the movie now but
really
once you see the movie sixth time that's
that's when it starts to get good okay
i've seen reviewers not wanting to give
the movie a rating right away because
they want to like it so badly they want
to make sure
that they like it
what movie will you give that sort of
criticism to what move
how do you not show incredible bias by
by admitting to that
like how how are you a reviewer if if
you need to watch it twice
to give it a review i've seen some
people deflecting saying okay well if
you didn't like star wars
that means you hate social justice and i
yes that that's true i do
but i didn't mind it in in this film i
thought it was all right
i it didn't take me away from anything i
didn't care it was nice to see
a strong female lead it was nice to see
a more more diverse
cast even though i hate forced diverse
casting i thought it was all right
i see so many people doing what i like
to call
twitter rick and morty deflecting
where someone or something is facing
criticism
and it's all just thrown away by
nitpicking one of the
many valid criticisms it's getting and
just
reducing that down to some sort of lower
iq
it's as the cash said ryan treats the
audience as if they are intelligent
and can work things out for themselves
some need to realize that the film
cannot do everything for you
to be fair you need extremely high level
of iq
to understand star wars when the pogs
hits the windshield of the millennium
falcon that is saying something deeper
about life if you didn't like star wars
that's because you you don't like social
justice if you don't like star wars
that's because you you're a fanboy it's
like
no none of these things applied i just
thought it wasn't
to put it simple i didn't like the film
because the characters felt hollow
the movie completely ignored common
sense
to further the plot in a way that i
think the most forgiving fan
would still cringe internally in
disbelief
the comedy was so out of place it felt
like i was watching avengers
and i think switching directors made
through in a trilogy
had the effect of all the setup from the
previous film
being completely thrown out the window
now i didn't
dislike everything about the film i
thought the cgi was
really cool there were some scenes that
were just mind-blowingly
amazing to look at i was like wow hey
marzia
that's pretty cool isn't it i really
like kylo ren and
rey's character and i think the movie
would have been a lot better if they
just focused on them
but let's get into all the bad stuff
first of all
the comedy my god
the movie started off with general hux
which in the first film was a very
serious character he was
he was almost like the reincarnation of
hitler
all of a sudden being in this movie in
the very first scene
comic relief it didn't make any sense at
all and as a viewer
you were completely taken out of the
film there was this weird prank call
with a pilot trying to
trying to distract him it felt like i
was watching austin powers or some some
saturday night live skit
of a parody of star wars fine you know
what if you want to make that joke
fine but changing a character's
personality completely for the sake of a
joke
why why uh then there's the porgs those
cute little
penguin things i like them i thought
they were all right
i i knew people were gonna hate them but
they were funny they were cute
and i like them and i will buy five of
them
six of them all of them i'll buy all of
them there was
one bit with the porks where
chewbacca is in the millennium falcon
and the porks are
in his cockpit and one of them is
wearing this
like headset thing it looks like he's
wearing a
vr headset and it was very cute
him doing that and it was very funny him
doing that
but it didn't make any sense him doing
that
i realized i'm probably nitpicking here
my point is i don't mind the jokes
i hated how they went out of their way
to make the joke
by having the poor wear wearing this vr
thing
it you're taken out of the universe
because it feels like a cartoon kind of
joke
it feel it felt like it was something
from space jam where it didn't really
make sense but it was still funny
constant ignoring common sense for the
sake of jokes there was this bit that
actually made me laugh where
rey is training with a lightsaber she
cuts up this piece
of the cliff the cliff falls down and
destroys the wagon
uh which one of the space nuns was
carrying it was funny because it was
unexpected
and uh my mind wasn't ready for it and i
left it was funny but then you're
thinking what if that rock hit the space
nun
she would legit have been murdered rey
would have been a murderer
it was so close if that happened to me
i'd be traumatized i'd be like shocked
i'd be like sorry space not
and i can't believe i did this but it
was more important that we
had this little joke that the lily punch
oh
it got hit by rock that's funny and the
last
joke that i remember which wasn't even
really a joke i can't tell
i can't tell if it was a joke or not but
luke skywalker
goes down to the beach we follow him
he's been living on this island and i
remember i went i whispered to marzia
like i wonder
how how does he eat on the island
and why does that happen he literally
just catches a fish out of nowhere
it was badass it was cool it was awesome
and i was like oh okay
that's how you know i got that question
internal question
answered and that was nice but then but
then luke goes to
down to the beach and i saw something
truly horrible there's this space
walrus sitting down like this
and he grabs a pacifier and he milks
the space walrus and then
he takes a huge chunk of the
space walrus milk going down his face
and then he goes
luke skywalker did this
why this is how i will always remember
luke skywalker the most beloved
character
the man who chugs down alien titty milk
like
[Music]
the second criticism which i had was the
characters feeling hollow
uh mainly because
you had so many amazing characters in
the film ray
kylo ren finn in the first movie they
were so cool to me i couldn't wait to
see what else they were gonna do with
them you know you had finn
a stormtrooper turned rogue they sort of
hinted that he had the force
uh in the first movie as well but in
this one
they uh someone apparently won
a competition to be part of the star
wars film and
had to hang out with finn the whole time
i swear to god this girl
made no sense their romance and story
was the most
worst romance i have ever seen in star
wars yes
yes yes worse than padme and anakin
yes seeing them kiss in the end was like
watching
someone kiss their sister it was
disgusting so basically
finn and rose go to this planet to
help be other people and they don't help
the other people
and it's really just 30 minutes of them
criticizing capitalism and how bad it is
yes that's right disney criticizing
capitalism
oh my god what was the point of the
casino planet
what was the point of it it didn't lead
to anything
it didn't do anything nothing happened
out of it
number three uh the the my favorite bit
was
how much it ignored common sense the
last bit
which is how much the movie ignored
common sense
to further the story you have this big
giant
enemy fleet you have the small good guy
fleet
they can't keep up with each other so
they're just following each other
why didn't the big guys send out small
ship
to shoot the the good guys
that would make too much sense i guess
rey didn't go through
any jedi training but could do
stop force pushes use the lightsaber
lift rocks she could do anything without
any
training okay fine
purple hair lady gets the question the
simple question
they're all gonna die on this ship right
and purple hair lady is
in command and everyone's like purple
hair lady
excuse me what is the plan we are all
literally dying here
and she doesn't tell anyone what the
plan is for the sake of the audience
not knowing what her plan is and it just
leads to all this trouble
for no reason she could have just told
everyone what
her plan was then she knew she was gonna
die in the end
she didn't do anything she just watched
all her friends get blown up
but then all of a sudden it just clicked
in her head
hey i'm gonna crash into them
with my ship i'm gonna kamikaze into the
bad guys
but i am only gonna realize this
after a lot of my friends have died
because i was too busy making sure my my
purple hair was purple what what the
[ __ ] they killed off admiral akbar one
of the most beloved characters in the
star wars
franchise what a classic meme and as a
meme appreciator myself
seeing him barely getting acknowledged
the fact that he died
was heartbreaking he you wouldn't get to
see him die
they just say hey admiral akbar
is dead why not replace purple hair lady
with admiral akbar have him be the one
crashing into the enemy ship which would
have been an emotional
ending to his character it would have
been an emotional set off
to one of the coolest scenes in the film
where you see the
the ship crashing to the other and it
would have been so cool
and i think that's why i'm so bothered
with this film because it just felt like
it's
massive ways of potential
simple things they could have changed
cut that
changed this and it could have been an
amazing film
but it wasn't i don't know why all these
critics are lying
so you have this ship crashing into the
enemy ship and
somehow
you have finn and rose escaping
from this ship in an escape pod they are
already
in the is in the ship department
they barely make it into the planet
meanwhile
the same ship have unloaded like seven
of these tie fighters
or whatever they're called and a cannon
on the ground
faster than they could just fly the ship
there
the movie just went we're on the planet
now and everyone is here
and it was just like what it was so
incredibly rushed
and this planet was so cool they have
like the salt on it
and then all the red underneath it was
dope they clearly gave a lot someone
really brilliant came up with this idea
that it was going to look really
visually cool but it was never utilized
properly
because they clearly ran out of time
because we spent 30 minutes
on the goddamn casino planet last but
not least i think switching directors
midway through a trilogy was a terrible
uh
idea and clearly anything that was set
up from the first film was thrown out
the window for the second one because
the directors had different ideas of
what was
important and it just made the whole
thing a mess to me
instead the movie gets praised for
reinventing star wars when in reality it
it's just a mess i'm fine with
reinventing star wars
just don't do it midway through a
trilogy right
tell me how that makes any sense for me
this really turned me off star wars
again
how many times are you gonna get let
down until you say
you know what at this point i don't
really care anymore and i think that's
where i am the movie has already made
220 million so
in everyone's eyes it's a massive
success so clearly nothing's gonna
change
but i found it really funny to see how
people were so desperate to defend it
even though
it's objectively bad
it's just a matter of wanting to not
look at all these bad things
and just focusing on all the good ones
and if you did that and if you manage to
get enjoyment out of that
then fair play to you i don't want
people to not like it but for me it was
impossible to watch this film
when all this [ __ ] was happening in the
background and just be like yeah that
was
really good you i've seen it six times
now and it actually got
really nice i always tend to be more
critical when i want things to be better
and when i know
things could have been better and i
definitely think that was the case for
the last jedi i wouldn't consider myself
a fan of star wars before this film
and i'm 100 off the train after this
film
i'm gonna give it uh 3.5
out of ten thanks for leaving a like i
imagine that this will get
a lot of dislikes so i appreciate it
let's get this
to trending squad fam out you and the
chosen one